pierre alors vous suivez donc cette
mobilisation en et elle est bien écouter
à samantha plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées ici cet
après midi du côté de l'assemblée
nationale vous l'avait dit pour
protester contre cette loi est sécurité
globale vous l'avez dit des centaines de
gilets jaunes sont tout d'abord arriver
ici sur cette place ils ont été rejoints
par notamment la ligue des droits de
l'homme et de nombreux
l'organisation syndicale comme la cgt
sud et puis le syndicat des journalistes
des cinq syndicats de journalistes qui
organisait une prise de parole pendant
de longues minutes je vous le disais
donc tous ici à présent pour dénoncer
cette loi de sécurité globale une loi
dont on va parler avec notre invité jean
lassalle bonjour jean lassalle bon sens
l'ait jamais merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur ft france l'école comme il
ya comme un mois et demi on était
n'étaient pas nombreux à interviewer
voudrait toujours été la roue avec
plaisir vous étiez tout à l'heure dans
l'assemblée nationale pour ce ce débat
comment ça se passe exactement à
l'intérieur le débat pour l'instant n'a
pas vraiment comment c'est là ont voté
le budget alors vous êtes venu en tout
cas ici pour soutenir un
ces manifestants qui qui sont justement
là pour lutter contre cette loi sécurité
globale pourquoi c'est important pour
vous d'apporter votre votre soutien
parce que comme c'est important pour moi
parce que comme je lé dé lorsqu'un de
mes fils me montrer pour la première
fois des six ans ce mouvement il venait
de naître
jeudi c'est le dernier mouvement
d'inspiration révolutionnaire j'ai su
tout de suite et compris et puis le
premier samedi je me suis rendu au rond
point dans la vie de droit sans tarir à
côté de chez moi
il y avait du monde partout dans les
ronds points pour faire exception
rond-point faut voir le fouloir même
temps les réacs signal très fort c'est
que on se réapproprie on se réapproprie
ce guetta nom sera entrepris tout ce que
d'autres ont pris à notre place et puis
après c'est les effets j'ai eu l'honneur
de participer à la plupart des vannes
est ici à paris vous parlez des délits
et jaune mais tout le monde ici aussi
est rassemblé pour justement dénoncer la
loi sécurité globale qui est
actuellement débattu à l'assemblée
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de
d'être là être soutenir tous ces
manifestants qui sont là aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que
première vue c'est le mouvement de celle
des jeunes et il faut le dire un peu eux
la cgt a
les vingt derniers qui ont amené
une réflexion là dessus mais ça c'est
en arrivant sur me faire pour se donner
bonne conscience la réponse c'est que je
pense tout le monde est très mal à
l'aise par la manière dont a été
littéralement matin puis des construit
de monts vendée gilet jaune
dernièrement il ya eu une quarantaine de
bornes y est
deux manifestations aussi violente
depuis un moment de temps dans le monde
la loi qui vient me fait me demander
pourquoi il faut encore on a rejoint
d'opposer les français rentrent parce
que c'est la seule chose qu'on va faire
moi il ya une réponse très simple que
j'attends je leur pose encore une fois
devant vous je vous remets coûté quand
est ce qu'on va identifier les 300
bonnes âmes tous habillés de noir qui
arrivait et puis tout d'un coup il se
mettait par petits groupes de cinq ou
six 3 mettez un gilet jaune et taper sur
les policiers et des trois centres
c'était
un noir et taper sur les gilet jaune et
s'était aussitôt les grenades qui
tendait donc c'est un élément très
important c'est la liberté de manifester
en france il a été terriblement met à
mal le message que porte le gilet jaune
était pourtant un message pacifique
c'est pareil engouement c
la gare quant aux policiers et les
gendarmes
les accusés de tous les maux c'est faux
j'étais avec eux sur le fond marin un
jour terrible oui de l'épousé qui est
aussi à votre caméra je vais répondre à
l'énergie si ça j'étais m'interposer
venir des années des centaines avaient
envie de se taper dessus
merci merci vous le voyez samantha
jean lassalle donc députés inquiets et
déçus sein de l'hémicycle l'hémicycle
donc pour soutenir les manifestants ici
il n'est pas le seul député est descendu
puisque à l'instant on vous a parlé de
nombreux députés de la france insoumis
sont venus également apporté leur
soutien aux centaines de manifestants
qui sont ici aujourd'hui du côté de
l'assemblée nationale merci beaucoup à
vous qui a refait sa vie et vernon merci
également à jean lassalle à vos côtés
chiens